bonjour venez vite encore plus près
voilà je suis en train de lire des
slogans publicitaires
vous savez ces phrases très courtes que
l'on entend dans les publicités celle
que jolie sont tout comme au kiosque
c'est une idée de transport faire un
concours de slogans publicitaires
il dit que cela pourrait attirer des
touristes dans l'île et que je vendrai
plus de bonbons je ne sais pas si ça va
marcher mais en tout cas l'idée amusé
presque tout le monde dans l'île
j'ai d'ailleurs reçu déjà plein de
réponses
écoutez si celle de monsieur palangrotte
le pêcheur chez julie tous les bonbons
sont aussi frais que mes saumon à celle
de mademoiselle futaie la botaniste vous
savez chez julie les bonbons sont bons
bonjour mademoiselle julie un bonjour
factor je suis en train de lire à nos
amis quelques exemples de publicités
pour ma boutique et vous avez des genres
aussi bonsoir oui c'est fantastique mais
ce pas oui et pour sûr il doit bien
d'avoir des formidables 1 on vous dira
la vérité facteurs je n'ai rien trouvé
encore d'extraordinaire alors vous
pensez que je peux avoir ma chance
pourquoi vous en afrique etc rien vaut
aussi pour tout vous dire mademoiselle
julie apporter justement donner le moins
étonné mais si vous savez ici c'est sans
prétention ouais mais je lis je vais
écrire le coeur à ça j'en suis certaine
facteurs et puis je les lisais le mois
moi je suis le facteur fervent
admirateur des bonbons délicieux et du
sourire gracieux de mademoiselle julie
qui est toujours poli temps passe et le
mans n'ont pas parlé franchement 1 ap
c'est très très jolie facteurs mais ça
n'est pas un slogan publicitaire c'est
c'est un véritable petit poème mais
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que ça vous
avez raison mais moi quand je commence
une peau ici et que les mots les mots
barry comme ça je ne sais plus comment
les arrêter à vous avez le car trop
générales facteurs peut-être bien et
julie mais dites moi monsieur du soulor
il ne vous a pas écrit une publicité si
bien sûr attendez à monsieur du snob
monsieur du sne hommes achètent tous ces
bonbons chez julie c'est tout dire
celui qui a écrit ça lui même aurait
pour source c'est pas la grande modestie
que voulez vous chacun a son caractère
vous avons tous nos petits défauts on
mais je ne le blâme pas au contraire je
vous savez que j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour monsieur 10,9 et casimir dites moi
hein mais il est au fond du jardin ou
regardez le il a l'air d'avoir des
problèmes pour trouver une idée un gps
cas ça c'est moi et 1000 hamilton
ouais ouais bonjour factor tu m'as l'air
bien grognon ce matin mais non j'essaye
de me concentrer depuis une heure je n'y
arrive pas tu veux dire que tu n'arrives
pas à penser à ce que tu veux écrire
seulement exactement pourtant l'île aux
enfants est bien connu pour son calme et
son silo ce mois justement ce sont les
chants d'oiseaux qui me gêne quand il
n'ya pas de bruit plus fort je ne veux
pas écrire des bruits weepu pour ne plus
entendre les chants d'oiseaux
et je suis plus de voir le nook curieuse
théorie et bien comme tu veux casimir
je vais te faire entendre le bruit idéal
j'en ai plein qui sont enregistrés
review du pourra choisir par lagaf' est
toi tu appelles les enfants oui bombay
julie moi je voulais c'était avantageux
j'ai jemma tourné à continuer à les
amusez vous bien
au revoir merci facteur voir des enfants
vous êtes tous là julie va vous
expliquer le jeu voilà les enfants vous
allez essayer de deviner quelles sont
les bruits que je fais écouter à casimir
et vous aussi chez vous vous cherchez
avec nous
alors attention ouvrez bien vos oreilles
le premier bruit c'est pas un oiseau
carole bouquet très bien c'est ça
[Musique]
isabelle l'ambulance c'est ça non la
police
tracteurs oui un marteau piqueur
christophe
ici voilà c'est pas tout à fait une scie
électrique mais très cette percée du
doigt la rentrée une perceuse électrique
[Musique]
qui voit là une sirènes de bateau
là aussi vous avez trouvé
[Musique]
fabien une course automobile vous avez
tout trouver ensemble un client est bien
casimir tu as choisi ton bruit quoi
qu'est ce que ça aille mais quel bruit
je te fais remarquer que c'est pour toi
que nous cherchons un bruit ah bon mais
je n'en ai plus besoin du tout non non
non ça y est avec tout le bruit que vous
avez fait j'ai pu me concentrer et j'ai
trouvé mon idée vous qu'est ce que c'est
voilà le slogan publicitaire
les bonbons d'eau jury sont aussi bon qu
elle est jolie au casimir